friend that always thinks i am the tiger
i am the tiger
that's even more happy
all right well who's the tiger here will
we have a winner will it be a draw at
the moment it looks like two tigers just
balancing each other out
really high level really intense chess
and magnus now just moving his king to
the side does this allow black to go and
capture a pawn with the black rook
ah magnus there we go one pawn drops off
and uh now the knight under fire from
the white rook
yeah magnus knows that the win is no
longer likely
what is most likely to happen is black
giving up the knight for that white a
pawn as we mentioned alice the a pawn
will cost black the knight but not
enough pawns left here we go knight
takes pawn is about to happen
and
the players i think they've just agreed
to a draw yeah you're about to draw rook
and game both shaking their head again
i mean it's been such a great day and it
takes it to the last game right so we're
shaking our heads in amazement they're
shaking their heads
so intense